big big companies from auto companies to
walmart 2-foot apparel companies like
Nike or coca-cola and food and beverage
and many others are now not only
thinking about this deeply but imposing
standards on all of their suppliers
which can number in the tens of
thousands and making requirements of
them to ship them less packaging less
waste more energy efficient less toxic
products and materials this does not
make them green companies this makes
that because I don't even know how to
define that we don't have a standard yet
for green company and nobody claims them
to be green including these companies
but but that means that they're they're
looking at both large and small things
and at the scale in which they operate
even small things can have a huge huge
impact give you just one little story
there's thousands of these a few years
ago McDonald's eliminated the embossed
golden arches on their napkins right
it's a little emboss school not just
probably know it no environmental
impacts of embossing that there's no you
know dot toxic dyes or heavy metals
maybe there's a little heat used in that
embossing process but what would happen
as a result well it made the napkins
24-percent thinner which means they can
fit twenty four percent more napkins in
a box twenty four percent more boxes in
a truck in a truck or tractor trailer
eliminating the need for shipping by the
equivalent of about a hundred tractor
trailers a year just from napkins now
that doesn't make McDonald's green
they're not green but the point is
they're doing hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of these things and so are
most companies out there we don't hear
about them they don't talk about them
you'd think that companies do in green
things in having significant impacts
would want to shout this stuff from the
rooftops but these in fact every company
wants green stories to tell everybody
feels they need to have one but the
reality is that green stories are hard
stories to tell for three reasons first
of all most of them are about doing less
bad right so if you have a widget in
this widget say hey this widget has
fifty-four percent fewer toxics than
last year that's a significant thing
from an environmental perspective but it
still means that hey we're beating our
wife forty-six percent of the time right
so that's not a very easy story to tell
however impactful it might be the
biggest reason is that a lot of these
things have no value to the to the
consumer in terms of the reason that
they buy a product so if anheuser-busch
would coca-cola if it figures out how to
bring out third of the aluminum in an
aluminum can which they've done over the
past decade or so and if you think of
that consider the environmental impacts
of mining bauxite to make aluminum or
the fact that manufacturing aluminum is
so energy intensive it's not one of the
top three or four or five greenhouse gas
amazing industries that's a significant
thing from an environmental achievement
but they're not going to put a green
seal on Bush and bud that's not why
people buy the stuff or if if if I
frito-lay I McDonald's or somebody who
makes potato chips you know sources
potatoes from a processor that now uses
closed-loop washing instead of flushing
the rinse water down the drain every
time they wash a load of potatoes they
now recycle it and use it over and over
filter it and you know and and all of
that saving hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of gallons of water a year
again a significant thing from an
environmental perspective but they're
not going to put a green label on a
holster fries or bag of potato chips so
it's these are things that you can't
always put on a hang tag or label or a
package or an advertisement but the
third reason is that when companies
start talking about what they're doing
right they often unwittingly illuminate
problems that the public didn't know
they had so a few years ago
I learned that that Levi Strauss which
at the time was the largest cotton buyer
in the world had started sourcing two
percent of their annual cotton by
organically and I thought that was a
really interesting story i called them i
wanted to write about it and they said
well we don't want to talk about it and
I persevered and I knew people there and
eventually I got them to talk with me
about it and of course one of the
questions I asked them was why don't you
want to talk about it they said well
look at it from our perspective when we
go out to tell this story we have to
explain why we're doing this first of
all that cotton is one of the hardest
crops to grow incredible and intensity
of pesticides and fertilizers and water
it's very hard to grow and and and and
then we have to talk about the impacts
of all that this pesticides and
fertilizers and the ground water runoff
and the impact on worker health and
safety and how that affects the birds
and the trees by the time we tell that
story we risk our customers saying so
you mean ninety-eight percent of what
you make is bad for people on the planet
why only two percent why not fight you
know we're going to do campus boycotts
so you commit to ten percent organic
cotton you can sort of hear that
conversation unfolding in the
marketplace and the conversation that
unfolded it Levi's is unfolding every
day at big companies which is to
basically ask the question do we do it
or do we talk about it or both and if we
talk about it how do we talk about it